[Musique]
addi bâ mamadou mouvement
12e régiment de tirailleurs sénégalais
sans crainte et sans rien faire avancer
comme les allemands sont chez eux
d'accord mais elle a plein d'autres
visuellement à 10 et là je mets des
dizaines ont pu s'échapper ont été
retrouvés dans les chemins drailles
fauré tofan comme les autres au boulot
je savais que je pouvais compter sur toi
cherchons à noyauter les administrations
recueillir le maximum d'informations à
l'intérieur
notre problème de construire un vrai
souci regret je travaille pour la
croix-rouge et lui c'est mon traducteur
producteur du pays s'est dit le par la
voix fait venir chez moi aussi bien sur
trois volets d'un avec le thé noir
selon présentement récré j'aurais pas
comme un frère à partir de maintenant
vous obéirez aux chefs militaires de ben
addi bâ
je n'arrive pas à lui faire confiance
pourquoi je suis confiant ce qu aux
montagnards votre coup de feu il va
faire 50 morts pour un soldat allemand
tué 50 français exécuté
désormais c'est la règle
les allemands en attendant qu'on voie
d'amendement d'ici la fin de ce mois
j'ai trois grands des étoiles cardio
neil
voudrais je voudrais n'être pas français
pour pouvoir dire que je t'ai choisi
france
mais quelle honte aux martyrs je devrai
peut la mettre encore en jeu le vautour
en batterie et magloire est mon unique
amour
[Musique]
lui c'est mon traducteur producteur
oui pourparlers avec les africains ne
cherchez pas c'est comme ça c'est les
accords entre gouvernements
français je m'appelle jean rousseau je
suis né à orléans
tu corriges kent
[Musique]
dans des anneaux
de plus
bon
face à cela
[Musique]
et
t'inquiète pas si ça se trouve il est
déjà passé en zone libre ton copain je
pense seulement 100 g unit des six mois